[Music]
hi I'm Justin Boz Derek I'm chef/owner
of speedy Romeo restaurant in Brooklyn
and Lower East Side so st. louis-style
pizza is one using that provel cheese
that the signifier that's what puts it
on the map that's what makes it unique
all the pizzas in st. Louis to use that
type of cheese they call it a mixture of
cheddar provolone and Swiss
there was a mayor in Saint Louis who
wanted to create a cheese to put them on
the map and so he wanted to cheese to be
the same consistency hot cold once you
cook it it get that caramelization on
top of them stays like creamy underneath
from there
cutting it in squares is another you
know stamp that makes it unique to st.
Louis as well and that Square party cut
is what they call so cooking process for
the st. Louie pizza is to shape the
dough we shape it into 12 inches and
then we put a thin layer of San Marzano
tomato sauce after the saucepan we have
six slices of thin hot sopressata
so a spicy almost pepperoni salami
flavor then from there we have
house-made Italian sausage so pour lots
of pecorino and Parmesan cheese toasted
fennel seed black pepper salt so little
dollops of that all over the pizza what
makes it the st. Louie pizza is the
provel cheese it's the consistency of
American cheese if you won't but it has
liquid smoke inside from there it gives
you that real rich umami flavor we put
more pecorino and Parmesan cheese chili
flake dried oregano and then from there
the pizza goes into the oven to coat our
oven ranges in the zone where we cook
the pizza from about 750 to 800 degrees
with it at that temp pizzas take about
90 seconds to two minutes to cook total
so it cooks you see the cheese do that
thing where caramel ice is on top stays
gooey underneath when it comes out then
we cut it into squares and then we
finish the pizza with pickled chilies
that acid and heat is great to balance
out that cream
cheesy flavor I grew up in Kansas City
my dad grew up in st. Louis once I knew
I was going to do a wood burning pizza
restaurant I selfishly brought the
provel in from st. Louis so that I could
eat it myself basically because I can't
get it anywhere around here now we're
bringing in like with both restaurants
close to 200 pounds a week of cheese
from st. Louis Brooklynites have come to
love the st. Louie pizza I was very
suspect when we first opened I didn't
think anyone would like it I thought
people would be stuck to their like New
York style pizza ways and not want to
try it but it's our second most popular
pizza you know once you have it it's
extremely craveable
[Music]